Beyonce gives birth to twins to be able  to experience bringing the child into  this world if you are lucky and  fortunate enough to experience that I  would never ever take that for granted  Queen B welcomes her second and third  child with husband jay-z the exciting  news comes after Beyonce broke the  Internet with this shot in February  announcing she was pregnant and blessed  two times over I wanted it to be  something iconic and something that  people will never forget she did not  miss a beat throughout her pregnancy  sharing several gorgeous maternity looks  as if her loyal beehive she showed off  her baby bump at a pre Oscars party it  was so much fun put on an iconic  performance at the Grammys and made a  rare appearance at the beauty in the  beef premiere with daughter Blue Ivy  [Music]  Congrats to the proud parents on their  new addition  [Music]